[Music]
my right hand man that's my shadow he
was trying to get no hair got no stick
just a chopper just to go to war it's
two words it's me him when you bs you
just hit the man you see gang upper
traffic we trying to underscore bang
bang no punches watch his body hit the
floor i should have popped him in the
shoulder watch his body spit some more
all you hear is cop cars and gunshots
that means sword mayday babysitting the
realest hit the door i heard that she
just left she finna bring back some more
off in the chase thanks i think i like
getting kind of bored hop on the ground
talking to this little [ __ ] i think
she's for beat the [ __ ] off the perk i
only hit cause i was bored
[Music]
[Music]
go and put a knife i know the second
side mad cause we get money and we pop
she let me hit it from the back she do
it right she let her pop it
dress top five bsg
[Music]
hey you guys just watched uh freestyle
uh presented by lrg shout out to lrg
they just did this phoenix suns collab
that is fire um and they got some of the
freshest gear in the world and right now
if you head over to lrg's website we're
gonna put it on the screen
and you use the promo code bootleg
you'll get 30 off at checkout that's 30
off as much clothes as you could put in
your [ __ ] cart at lrg's website l
r g dot com
use the promo code bootleg save 30
off we got another freestyle coming next
week presented to you by lrg